today's episode is sponsored by blinka
Stu the app that lets you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blink it's totally
free and get 25% off a subscription when
you go to blink Escom slash david pakman
I put the link right below this video
what a crazy weekend it's good to be
back and there's so much to talk about
we have a big media story free speech
story censorship story actually it's
really just a media story advertisers
are fleeing Fox News propagandist Tucker
Carlson's program why because of
constantly racially charged and quite
frankly boring and predictable nonsense
that is totally toxic and right away the
whole I don't really understand the
First Amendment crowd is out in force
defending Tucker Carlson against second
I'm sorry First Amendment not Second
Amendment First Amendment
misunderstandings and so-called charges
of censorship but what we're actually
seeing is the marketplace of ideas that
these right-wingers claim to want and
I'm going to get to that a little bit
later after explaining to you what took
place being associated with Tucker
Carlson's program is bad for some
advertisers in the marketplace and they
are making the decision to bail so just
the other day Tucker Carlson said on his
show the protests aren't really about
black lives and that ominously they will
come for you it wasn't clear when he
said it if he meant black people or who
later claimed that he meant Ono
Democrats I guess here's what he had to
say this may be a lot of things this
moment we're living through but it is
definitely not about black lives and
remember that when they come for you and
at this rate they will and he was ever
been subjected to the rage of the mob
knows the feeling it's like being
swarmed by Hornets you cannot think
clearly a bunch of companies that had
been advertising on Tucker Carlson's
program decided to pull their
advertising because of that and other
clips it wasn't just one thing
apparently
this includes Disney this includes Papa
John's Pizza which is historically a
horrible horrible
a t-mobile Poshmark and some other
brands so in a second we're going to
talk about the free speech and
censorship component to this because the
misunderstandings that are floating
around are disturbing in terms of the
lack of understanding of anything
related to speech and censorship that
they that they portray but I want to be
really like extra super clear about
something here I said this is just
business and this is just business it's
a market decision that's being made by
these companies Papa John's said they
are deciding to stop all advertising on
opinion shows in general it's not that
they're particularly upset with what
Tucker said they're making a business
decision to pull advertising from all
opinion programs the other advertisers
are the Papa John's and other
advertisers they're not bailing on Fox
News there are there they're not saying
the problem is that Fox is so
harebrained that they allow Tucker
Carlson a platform to say this stuff
they're just moving from Tucker Carlson
to other fox news shows that are less
under the microscope Fox News said that
these departures aren't causing a
financial hit because it's just moving
money from Tucker's show to other shows
so these are not political decisions in
general in the sense that these are
companies that are still okay sending
money to Fox News and they are okay with
Fox News carrying water in general for
Donald Trump and the terrible ideas
espoused by Donald Trump and and by the
network but they're not going to do it
on Tucker Carlson's show because it's
just become negative attention getter so
to speak so now that gets us to the
First Amendment free speech component
which for me is really the most
interesting thing a whole bunch of Trump
supporting right-wingers are saying this
is censorship of Tucker Carlson there's
a free speech violation First Amendment
you know fill in the blanks with your
generic censorship concern trolling
language and then let's debunk these
claims one by one first of all this has
nothing to do with the First Amendment
this is the participants here our
advertisers at
TV channel and the TV host and the
audience first amendment is not a factor
here the government is not abridging
anyone's speech whatsoever so first
amendment into the trash out the window
second this is how capitalism in the
marketplace of ideas works understand
that there's no coercion happening here
there's you know the the the
non-aggression principle people should
be pleased Tucker Carlson can choose I
guess he's allowed to say whatever he
wants on his program and that may have
repercussions Fox News is totally free
no coercion Fox News confuse to employ
Tucker or not they may have a particular
contract with them where if they pull
him off the air they still gotta pay
them but they in Tucker Carlson agreed
on that contract with no government
intervention advertisers can choose to
advertise on any show they want or not
to for any reason they can say I don't
like the the suits that Tucker Carlson
wears or I don't like what Tucker
Carlson says they are free to decide
however they want to or not to advertise
on any particular program viewers like
you can choose to watch or not watch
Tucker Carlson viewers can choose to
contact advertisers and say if you
advertise with Tucker I will no longer
buy your stuff or they could say unless
you advertise with Tucker I won't buy
your stuff everybody's free to do
whatever they want period and
interestingly the advertiser can choose
again non-aggression no coercion if
you're an advertiser and people start
writing to you saying you'd better stop
advertising with Tucker or you'd better
start advertising with Tucker
either way the advertiser can choose to
listen to those people or not everybody
gets to make their choices now you're
going to hear some people pop up and
they are they're either ignorant or
their concern trolling and they will say
if you email a company and say I will
not buy your stuff if you do X or Y like
advertising with Tucker that's coercion
it's not coercion
it's called speech there's no violence
it's a marketplace this is literally
what the free marketeers claim to want
is a buyer
can choose to buy or not buy a product
for any reason that is important to me I
is a buyer and free to tell a company
why I am buying their product or why I
am not buying their product and the
company can choose whether to pay
attention to me or whether to tell me to
go to hell and do whatever they want the
company can decide you know if we
advertise with Tucker we're gonna lose a
thousand customers but we might gain two
thousand because his audience is so big
and that extra thousand customers is
worth it to us despite the PR problem
that it might cause us to advertise with
dr. Carlson and they can decide whatever
they want the market is actually
regulating itself here without violence
or government intervention the
right-wingers should be cheering this
but they're not they want to frame it as
a liberal mob trying to hurt someone's
ability to earn a living we don't even
know by the way whether Tucker's income
is affected by the number of advertisers
his show has it may not be we don't know
they are pathetic and they are
predictable and they're so boring I mean
we're it's just it's getting so old that
they either don't understand or pretend
not to understand how markets and free
speech and censorship actually work
here's something very interesting and
gross I want to be clear but we're
looking at it from from a perspective of
electoral politics the Trump 2020
campaign and the 2020 Republican
platform in the last three days have
confirmed and gone back to being more
anti-gay and more anti trans now the
reason this is interesting is that
Donald Trump never ran as your
traditional socially conservative
anti-gay Republican he very decidedly
focused during his campaign in 2015 and
2016 on really an economic populist
message is right-wing populism but it's
an economic populist message I'll fix
trade because trade and these trade
deals NAFTA China the they're screwing
the average person I'm gonna protect our
borders and therefore protect jobs for
average people that type of language was
Trump's focus in 2016 and we showed we
we saw the
of that during the Republican primary of
2016 where the evangelical and the
Christian support was more around other
candidates Ted Cruz as an example I
forget who else had early Christian
support now eventually the Christians
came around and mostly voted for Donald
Trump because number one they certainly
weren't going to vote for Hillary
Clinton
number two Trump started counting to
them a little bit he told this
completely unbelievable story about how
despite being pro-choice his entire life
he essentially met a kid he liked a
friend of his had a kid that he liked
and and the person had thought about
getting an abortion and that made Trump
see the light and have an awakening
where he was now against abortion
totally unbelievable but he played to it
said the Bible is his favorite book up
there with art of the deal so eventually
the Christians came over to him but the
anti-gay message was not a big part of
Donald Trump's campaign the anti-gay
rhetoric for Republicans has
historically been a really great way to
raise money even if the anti-gay crowd
is not as big as it once was they will
still donate if they believe that you're
with them on so-called family values
which typically include being anti-gay
so Donald Trump and the Republican Party
seems so desperate right now to stop the
damage that is being done by trumps
presidency to the Republican Party that
they are bringing back an anti-gay focus
and it's because they're desperate so
Trump sees the numbers women are going
to Biden in record numbers young people
are sticking with Biden older folks are
going with Biden and the idea is let's
get back to the anti-gay focus of five
or ten years ago and try to pull in some
people particularly people who will
donate a lot of money so on Friday the
Trump administration rolled back an
Obama era transgender healthcare
protection that's part of Obamacare and
what they're doing is returning to the
government's interpretation of sex
discrimination according to what they
call the plain meaning of sex as male or
female determined by biology so this
essentially dismisses any concept of
treating trans people in accordance with
their sexual identity and all of
protections associated with that would
go away the Republican National
Committee has also now called
for just leaving their 2016 platform
unchanged and making it their 2020
platform that is a platform that called
for banning same-sex marriage now the
timing remember June 2015 the Supreme
Court said states can't ban same-sex
marriage anymore so it de facto made
same-sex marriage legal nationally that
was June 2015 the Republican primary was
already starting to get going then and
the Republican platform contained
opposition to same-sex marriage at that
time despite what the Supreme Court said
now over the last four years as you
probably know even among Republicans
public opinion has been moved more and
more into same-sex marriages okay this
is not something we really want to fight
about anymore and the anti-gay activism
has focused more around religious
freedom not baking cakes that sort of
thing but Republicans have decided
they're gonna keep that as part of their
2020 platform ban same-sex marriage so
understand this is not an oversight this
is part of continuing to counteract the
unpopularity of Donald Trump and the
fact that this is also dragging down a
bunch of different Senate candidates
Joni Ernst now we saw is doing poorly
we're gonna talk about that so they're
going back to their old faithful methods
of bringing in bigots and raising money
so the same platform that they are
reinstating supports can so-called
conversion therapy for LGBT individuals
the idea that typically religious type
services that they call therapy I don't
call it therapy can convert your sexual
orientation or gender identity they want
to continue supporting the rights of
businesses to discriminate against
people on the basis of their sexual
orientation or gender identity which
remember in some states is already
illegal by state law in other states it
is very much legal now there is some
other stuff thrown in there as well so
in total what we are seeing you know
Trump's 2016 campaign was an outlier in
terms of Republican campaigns there's no
doubt
but now in the face of polls that look
really bad for Donald Trump they are
going back to the old faithful tactics
of Republican candidates do the anti-gay
stuff again pander to racists we're
seeing examples of that lately pander to
xenophobes they're doing it all this is
the strategy pander to the worst of the
worst hope that the economy bounces back
just enough between now and November
that you can justify hey vote to
re-elect me and the third part of this
sort of Hydra is suppress enough of the
vote that along with pandering to the
racists and the homophobes and a slight
improvement in the economy you can get
enough votes to get yourself reelected
now remember if we go out and vote in
overwhelming numbers this won't work if
we don't go out and vote in overwhelming
numbers it actually may get Donald Trump
re-elected let me know what your
thoughts are I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
remember you can subscribe to the daily
audio podcast of the show on any one of
your favorite podcasting platforms and
lastly tomorrow night 8 p.m. Eastern the
David Pakman show
chess tournament number two a weird this
is it's just for fun everybody can play
skill level doesn't matter to sign up
for the tournament go to david
pakman.com slash chess it is free free
free it's just fun that's all it is I
will be playing tomorrow Tuesday June 16
8 p.m. Eastern sign up for the
tournament at david pakman.com slash
chess the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read ten books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka Stan what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blink as' to
get a sample first just think how much
you can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire non-fiction book in
just 15 minutes I recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
Stephen Hawking this is a book that I
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
accom slash david pakman i've put the
link right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are George Newhall and Jake Tebow
thank you to both of you for supporting
the program also a big thank you to Alan
Castle Alan is today's longtime
sustaining member of the day membership
is our primary funding source money
doesn't grow on trees we've many many of
us have been told and it also doesn't
just appear in our bank account for the
show we do depend on the support of
folks who go to join pakman.com and grab
a membership very cheap very quick very
easy and you will get the daily bonus
show which people love I'm reading
everywhere that people just absolutely
love it okay guys I have news for you
that may surprise you we may not have a
second wave of coronavirus but the
reason why is not so good it's because
the first wave may actually never end we
are already now halfway into June and it
doesn't seem like the first wave is
going to end at least at the national
level because of a number of new
exploding exploding hot spots the
out-of-control case growth is happening
overwhelmingly in Trump states states
with Republican governors so first let's
get this out of the way cuz I know
people are going to want me to talk
about California now California is the
exception here California is is a state
with a Democratic governor they have
been on paper locked down for a very
long time but things are not going well
in California I have no interest in
hiding this from you California has been
so-called closed for months but their
cases are going higher and higher
not precipitously but they are going up
it's not clear what's going on my
brother lives in LA says seems a lot of
people are just ignoring the guidelines
that he drove by some restaurants that
were open with people sitting inside
without masks so it seems as though
what's happening in California at least
Southern California is people are just
ignoring the guidelines that are in
place but most of the early contagion
states that were early hotspots have
curves that are looking really really
good an example of that is New York
State dramatically turning their car
around here in Massachusetts I'm just
genuinely thrilled to see that our curve
has fallen off a cliff there's a spike
last week if you're looking at the chart
it's a it's a false spike because on
that day they added presumptive cases
from the prior three months so that's a
bit of a it looks weird but we've only
got around 200 new cases per day here
there are only a couple hundred people
total I'm talking about in the entire
state left in IC use outdoor dining is
safely reopening I sat outside at a cafe
this weekend I put a picture of me doing
it on Instagram you'll see just how safe
it is but in the meantime while things
are improving dramatically in many
states a ton of right-wing states that
reopened early or never fully closed are
failing hard and it is difficult to
watch in Florida
spiking so aggressively that the chart
I'm showing it almost looks wrong but
that is the real data to the extent that
it is not being understated by Florida
which has been a problem in Florida then
in Texas again cases climbing more and
more and more with worse and worse
looking numbers we look at Arizona where
I have a bunch of friends Arizona it's
climbing in Arizona as if we're at the
beginning their friends told me almost
nobody's wearing masks and doors and
stores
everything's open people are pretending
everything's fine and indeed the case
numbers in Arizona reflect it there are
others we could look at North Carolina
is a big one we're also cases just will
not stop climbing so let's talk about
something now because I want it I want
to deal with the disinformation
propaganda that's going around ahead of
time so that you will be prepared to
fight it when you see it there's a
narrative that we're hearing from the
right that the problem with coronavirus
in the United States is Democrats in
power because the early hotspots are all
liberal cities and Democrats are
terrible at running cities and it's
chaos and that's why we have if it
weren't for democratic led cities this
never would have been a problem in the
United States now most of you know that
that's ridiculous
but they will then go on to say because
of those early failures by
at governors and mayor's the virus has
now spread to red states even though red
states did all of the right things and
blue states that all of the wrong things
they're also now starting to blame
Mexico for some of the spikes in places
like Texas in Arizona there is no
evidence of that so this is a completely
disjointed sort of sort of Gish gallop
narrative that they are putting together
and I want to give you a coherent sort
of unified theory for what's going on
here the early hot spots were caused by
two things population density and many
direct flights to the area's most
affected where the early cases were
coming from right the early hotspots in
the United States were New York San
Francisco California Chicago Boston as
examples these are four of the densest
those are actually the four densest
metro areas in the country
not necessarily high as population mmm
but highest population density and they
have tons of flights to Asia and Europe
here in Boston we had non-stop flights
to multiple Chinese cities tons of
flights to even more Chinese cities via
Hong Kong and Tokyo and other places we
had non-stop flights to Italy other
European cities where we now know
coronavirus already was there in late
2019 and early 2020 same thing Illinois
was an early hotspot Chicago O'Hare
Airport major hub for American Airlines
of flights United Airlines I'm going
from memory here San Francisco tons of
flights to China and other Asian
countries were with one stop you can get
to even more cities in China New York
has multiple major airports New York has
LaGuardia New York and JFK Newark and
JFK both individually are some of the
major gateways to Europe and to Asia and
you had two of them there so that's why
early on the cases started in those
places and right-wing states often said
then we don't have to do that much
because we're not having a problem these
blue states to different degrees lock
down and started mitigation in case is
slowly trickled throughout the country
into red states but a lot of the red
states never fully
closed or did but reopen quickly or did
but people ignored the guidelines and
overtime the early hot spots that were
brutally hit because of the population
density and the flights to the hot the
the early areas in Europe and Asia were
mitigated but the red states meanwhile
we're just churning as is a popular new
phrase on the internet churning cases
and when you look at the timing
yeah the blue cities were the early hot
spots but you look at the curve it was
up and then down because of what was
done look at some of the red states in
March they really weren't having a
problem in April they were only having a
small problem but when you look at the
curves now they haven't even peaked
these curves are horrifying it's just up
up up and in ten days it could be
absolutely insane in some of these
places I'm genuinely glad right now to
be in Massachusetts where everybody's
wearing masks at indoor businesses our
positive test rate is down yesterday it
was like 1.5 percent of all the tests
done yesterday 98.5 percent of the
people tested did not have the virus
that's a very very good sign what's
going on in these other states is
absolutely horrifying now just one more
thing to protect you from disinformation
the right-wingers are also insisting
cases are up in red states because
there's so much testing going on in
those places this is not true the data
is available take Florida as an example
Florida recently had a 36% increase in
new cases but only an 18% increase in
testing the positive test rate went up
to 7.5% on that day in Florida if you
test more people and find a higher
percentage of positives that's not good
and they will also say well cases may be
up but hospitalizations and deaths
aren't those are on a 10 to 20 day delay
so the cases that are increasing now
will be followed by deaths and
hospitalizations tragically over the
next 10 to 20 days don't fall for the
bogus talking points understand what's
going on and recognize we may not have a
sec discreetly identifiable second wave
because the first wave may
never end I have some fascinating video
to dig into today Donald Trump has been
having trouble on the issue of race
lately Donald Trump's reaction to huge
national protests against police
brutality after George Floyd was killed
by police was to say send in more force
and have the military dominate the
protesters that was the word he used
last week or the week before on a call
with governors so it's obviously not
going well for Trump on race Donald
Trump is polling 8% with black voters
eight eight percent according to a new
CNN poll so someone got the bright idea
let's send Trump to be interviewed on
Fox News but not by one of their
ubiquitous white blond anchors have
black woman harris faulkner interview
donald trump this is going to be great
it's gonna help him with with black
voters
it was absolutely and utterly insane and
I want to look at some clips with you
today
here's Trump pulling out the cringe
worthy claim about him doing more for
black people than any other president
and he weirdly says let's not include
Lincoln in that although he adds it is
questionable how much Abraham Lincoln
really did for black people to which
even Fox News anchor harris faulkner has
to say well we are free mr. president
like Lincoln freed the slaves you've
done more for us to check out this first
clip and strap in folks because it's
going to be wild
it's just in general I mean the economy
is the great unifier I think I've done
more for the black community than any
other president and let's take a pass on
Abraham Lincoln because he did good
although it's always questionable you
know in other words the end result we
are free mr. president but we don't be
well I'm going to take a pass a name
Honest Abe as we call she say you
absolutely bizarre this is the president
talking like this and he doesn't even
have the historical understanding to be
able to recognize how cringy this is
like its total cringe but he doesn't get
it because he lacks historical knowledge
Trump who has defended Confederate
monuments says he's done more for black
people than any other president so then
we get into the meat of it as it were
related to the protest
and Donald Trump says and this really
requires some deep thinking to know what
on earth is this guy talking about Trump
says that police chokehold as a concept
are innocent and perfect innocent and
perfect and then he totally dissembles
into nonsense yeah and I think the
concept of choke all sounds so innocent
so perfect and then you realize if it's
a one-on-one now if it's two-on-one
that's a little bit of a different story
depending depending on the toughness and
strength you know we're talking about
toughness and strength we are talking
there's a physical thing here also but
if a police officer is in a bad scuffle
and he's got somebody you have to be
careful what is he talking about I'm not
I'm not asking rhetorically what is he
talking about now understand that there
are lots of Republicans who will say
only 8% of black voters support Trump
because they've been somehow tricked by
Democrats or they've fallen for
something which implicitly suggests
black voters are dumb that they they've
been tricked by Democrats watch this
interview and you understand why Trump
is polling 8% with black voters here's
more about chokeholds Trump saying
sometimes bad people something-something
chokeholds are good that's I mean I have
a hard time making more sense out of it
than that say no I don't want to see
mistakes yeah I don't like Joe calls now
I will say this as somebody that you
know you grow up and you wrestle and you
fight and you this or you see what
happens sometimes if you're alone and
you're fighting somebody's tough and you
get somebody in a chokehold what are you
gonna do say oh and it's a real bad
person and you know that and they do
exist I mean we have some real bad
people you saw that during the last
couple of weeks you saw some very good
people protesting do you saw some bad
people also and you get somebody in a
chokehold and what are you gonna do now
let go and say oh let's start all over
again I'm not allowed to have you in a
chokehold
it's a tough situation now if you have
two people or another case and the case
that we're talking about two or four
people and two of them I guess just
pretty much started it's a very very
very tricky situation
so the chuckling is good because to talk
about because off-the-cuff it would
sound like absolutely but if you're
thinking about it then you realize maybe
there is a bad fight and the officer
gets somebody in a position I think you
have to probably see you want to be in
that conversation it's just not of this
world there's there's nothing there
there's no substance there to even
really analyze another absolutely Looney
Tunes moment from this interview they
get into the phrase Trump used when the
looting starts the shooting starts Trump
used this phrase during the protests
recently the origins are a guy named
Walter Headley the police chief of Miami
Florida who said it in the 60s when
there was a violent of outbreak of crime
and it has a horribly racist history it
was positioned against the battle for
civil rights in the country at the time
and Trump was asked about the origins
and he kind of plays dumb he's like well
other people also said it like Philly
Police Commissioner Frank Rizzo used the
term now Rizzo did not actually use the
term but he did encourage brutal police
tactics and Trump just kind of says like
well Rizzo also said it which is not
technically true and then it gets just
really awkward if you if you have an
aversion to awkwardness I would maybe
skip the next two minutes me and and I'm
Paris on TV but I'm a black woman I'm a
mom and you know when and you've talked
about it but we haven't seen you come
out and be that consoler in this
instance and the tweets when the looting
starts the shooting starts why those
words so that's an expression I've heard
over the years and India where I used to
I think Philadelphia the mayor of
Philadelphia the morning he comes from
1967 I was about 18 months old at the
time everybody's shooting wiki because
they probably got it wrong
but it was from the chief of police in
Miami he was cracking down and he meant
what he said and he said I don't even
care if it makes it look like brutality
I'm gonna
when the looting starts the shooting
starts that frightened a lot of people
when you you told it also comes from a
very tough mayor who I might have been
police commissioner at the time but I
think mayor of Philadelphia named Frank
Rizzo and he had an expression like that
but I've heard it many times so I think
it's been used many times it means two
things very different things one is if
there's looting there's probably going
to be shooting and that's not as a
threat that's really just a fact because
that's what happens and the other is if
there's looting there's going to be
shooting this is very they're very
different meanings I'm interesting no
there's very different meanings but I
think do you think most people see it
that way I think they see both was no I
mean I've had it viewed both ways I
think it's meant both ways can anybody
understand what he's talking about like
literally what is he saying I'm feeling
like my grammatical knowledge of English
is not up to par to properly parse what
Donald Trump is trying to say here so
let's now go backwards a little bit I'm
gonna go back to the start of the
interview with harris faulkner and trump
characterizes the protests really as
riots and unnecessary of course they
were mostly peaceful protests and they
were totally warranted given the
inaction on police brutality for so long
just completely dismissive Trump is of
the entire movement not exactly an
opportunity for a big coup with black
voters it's happened in the last couple
of weeks I feel like we are at one of
those historical moments where future
generations will look back and they'll
decide who we were are you the president
to unite all of us given everything
that's happening right now well I
certainly think so and I certainly hope
so and the relationships we have are
incredible the spirit of this country
and especially considering what happened
and when we had out of nowhere a plague
come in from China he just came in and
it came to all over the world it went
all over the world he looked at 186
countries and they were devastated and
we were certainly hit very hard
some were hit harder than us relatively
but we were hit very very hard
and now we're making our comeback and
then on top of it we had the the riots
which were unnecessary to the extent
they were if the governors and mayor's
would have taken a stronger action I
think the riots would have been you
could call protesters you could call
them riot so different nights different
things says riots again says riots again
says you could call them protests but
they're really riots and then following
up this dismiss at dismissiveness with
even more remember they sat him in front
of black fox news anchor harris faulkner
i guess as part of the optics here and
he just says horrible things here Trump
says lots of the protest protesters
didn't even know why they were
protesting which is just completely
dismissive of the movement when he
called out mom on that tape it's a heart
punch so I'm curious from you what do
you think the protesters not not the
looters and the riders we're intelligent
enough to know the difference in our
country right what do you think they
want what do you think they need right
now from you so I think you had
protesters for different reasons and
then you had protesting also because you
know they just didn't know I've watched
I watched you very closely why are you
here and they really weren't able to say
but they were there for a reason perhaps
but a lot of them really were there
because they following the crowd a lot
of them they were there because what we
witnessed was a terrible thing what we
saw was a terrible thing and we've seen
it over the years we haven't you know
this was one horrible example but you've
seen other terrible examples you know
that better than anybody would would
know it yes black woman harris faulkner
would know better than anyone but again
protesters didn't know why they were
there according to Donald Trump so
listen you can find people who were out
there who were just trying to cause
trouble or going with the crowd but the
answer is the overwhelmingly peaceful
protests were there because of police
brutality you say that first not as an
aside or at the end completely
disastrous interview but two totally
level with you I don't know that it
matters
anybody who would be disgusted with this
interview is already not voting for
Donald Trump anybody who just watches
Fox News and gets in line and is
planning to vote for Trump is going to
vote for him anyway regardless of this
interview so we've got to hit that slice
who might change their minds and I don't
know that many of those folks are
actually going to see this interview
it's tragic it's sad because this is
really exposing the lack of critical
thinking and and sort of thoughtfulness
and introspection that Donald Trump
experiences a total lack of and it's you
know if you really sit down and listen
to each of his answers you understand
the guy understands nothing he just
knows nothing he doesn't even you know
he he's there for a particular reason
there's a reason that with what's going
on he's being interviewed by harris
faulkner and he still fails to keep it
together in the way that this type of
strategy would hope that he would be
able to do just absolutely insane we're
going to have more clips from this
interview on the david pakman show
Instagram which is at David Pakman show
on my Instagram David Pakman you can see
me at a socially distanced outdoor cafe
over the weekend an incredible moment
just I just sat down outside somewhere
and it felt like a huge thing that's on
my Instagram David [ __ ] we'll take a
quick break and be back after
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the david pakman show depends
on your support and the easiest way is
through membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show so Donald Trump
delivered a completely bizarre and
self-congratulatory and berry deranged
graduation speech at West Point over the
weekend it was riddled with failed
applause lines but most notably at one
point Donald Trump visibly struggled to
raise a glass of water to his mouth and
later struggled to walk down a ramp
almost having to be helped down the ramp
by a member of the military now I'm
going to show you the video and we're
going to talk about it but this is as
much a story about right-wing hypocrisy
as it is a story about Donald Trump's
cognitive and physical state if Joe
Biden did 20% of what Trump did at this
speech over the weekend it would be a
week of Fox News and oay an adjective
I'd and has dementia with judge Jeanine
bringing in someone whose cousin's
girlfriend once went to medical school
to say that Joe Biden is unfit to lead
if this was Hillary it would be Hillary
Parkinson's times 10 all over again and
yet here they are pretending like
there's just nothing to see here
other than so-called Trump derangement
syndrome and by the way Trump
derangement syndrome is a term that the
right has developed to not have to
address criticisms of Donald Trump you
say something about Trump you have Trump
derangement syndrome it's a way to stop
conversation so first of all at one
point during the speech Donald Trump
goes to drink water picks up a glass
with his right hand brings it about 80%
of the way to his lips his right hand
seemingly could go no higher he tries
moving his mouth down to bring
down enough to get to the glass couldn't
do it and eventually uses his left hand
to very strangely pull the glass towards
his mouth and tilted it wasn't clear if
the problem was with trump's right arm
with his hand-eye coordination we just
have no idea but this is not a normal
way to drink water and it's the second
time at least that we've seen Donald
Trump bizarrely drink water in this way
then the other sort of most notable
moment during the speech was Trump
descending the ramp at the end of the
speech very gingerly carefully like he
was about to fall over very strange and
then he took a sort of hop step at the
bottom of the ramp which he later
described as jogging down the last ten
feet which we'll get to you'll also
notice that the officer gesturing
gesturing for Trump to leave the stage
and then walking next to him implies
that the officer was briefed ahead of
time stay with Trump going down the ramp
so again we've seen Trump come off of
Air Force One sometimes with the help of
an aide we've seen various versions of
this he just doesn't look stable when
he's walking here so is this the most
important thing going on right now it's
not but again if this was Joe Biden it
would be a week on right-wing media
about how this proves Biden simply
cannot be President it's also aggravated
and becomes more interesting by Trump
immediately lying about it Trump
tweeting quote the RAM that I descended
after my West Point commencement speech
was very long and steep now it's not
very steep had no handrail and most
importantly was very slippery it was a
sunny day it was totally dry there's not
really any reason why it would be
slippery and people who were there said
it was not slippery and then Trump
saying the last thing I was going to do
is fall for the fake news to have fun
with final ten feet I ran took down to
ground level that's also a lie Trump
sort of took a two step hop he did not
run ten feet so it always attracts more
attention and his worse when Trump
starts lying about it there's also a
tweet for everything with Trump Trump
once criticized Barack Obama for how he
would walk out of Air Force One tweeting
in 2014 that quote
Obama should stop running down the
stairs when getting off Air Force One
doesn't look presidential and at some
point he will take a fall never happened
and by the way we have video of Barack
Obama on the same ramp that Trump was on
Obama certainly looking very very spry
nothing to sneeze at there so this is
all very weird and we don't really have
an explanation which I'll get back to
the speech was also filled with a ton of
really other weird moments Trump at one
point attempting to talk about former
president ulysses s grant he called him
you Lysias a couple of times didn't we
lead we need you to carry on the spirit
of the great general ulysses s grant
that's weird then also struggling with
the name Douglas MacArthur seemingly
saying MacArthur MacArthur really just
multiple times we need you to be as bold
and determined as the immortal General
Douglas MacArthur who knew that the
American soldier never ever quits after
leaving the Philippines for Australia at
a low point of the Pacific War
in 1942 MacArthur famously had I shall
return and then maybe the most
cringe-worthy moment was Trump's failed
applause line when he mentioned the two
hundred and forty fifth birthday of the
army and paused and looked around it was
complete crickets and then Trump decided
to bring up his own birthday I mean this
is real cringe tomorrow America will
celebrate a very important anniversary
the two hundred and forty fifth birthday
of the United States Army unrelated
going to be my birthday also I don't
know if that happened by accident did
that happen by accident please but it's
a great day because of that army
birthday so a absolutely embarrassing
speech now as far as the medical stuff
Trump couldn't lift a glass of water
with his right arm
he seemed when he was walking down that
ramp that he was
kind of favoring his left side if
someone wanted to speculate about what's
going on in that there seems to be a
left-right
issue here you would start thinking
about stroke remember that he was taken
on short notice to Walter Reed Hospital
that time they lied and said oh we
decided to get a jump on his 20/20
physical that was back in 2019 totally
not believable you start to imagine
because they don't fill in the details
maybe there's something going on here
that could be stroke related now
remember it's speculative we don't know
and the the important thing to remember
is if it were Biden they would be saying
this video is proof that Biden should be
dropping out of the race really really
crazy stuff I told you about six weeks
ago that the Trump administration's
then-new strategy on the virus would be
to pretend the virus has been fixed we
are past the peak they were saying
they're not going to do any more press
briefings with doctors very little
talking about the virus or treatments or
vaccines they'll instead focus on
reopening the economy restaurants
recovery all of that stuff and that's
exactly what happened and meanwhile as I
already told you earlier cases have
exploded in places like Florida which is
hitting higher and higher new highs in
terms of cases every day
places like Texas whose curve is
slightly less horrifying than Florida's
but still really bad so what does Donald
Trump do he decides he'll have a huge
rally in Tulsa Oklahoma because that's
how you pretend things are totally
normal except things aren't totally
normal and they know it because when you
go to register for tickets you have to
accept a waiver that says if you catch
coronavirus at the rally you will not
hold Trump's campaign or the event
organizers responsible the exact wording
is that by clicking register below you
acknowledge that an inherent risk of
exposure to kovat 19 exists in any
public space where people are present by
attending the rally you and any guests
voluntarily assume all risks related to
exposure to Cove at 19 and agree not to
hold Donald Trump for president the be
up the BOK Center or anybody else liable
for illness or injury that sure doesn't
sound like things are normal and that
certainly doesn't sound like it's the
type of situation where you should be
having a
huge rally now of course Trump is
protecting himself
Trump's protecting his campaign but will
he be protecting the people who were
there will they hand out masks to
everybody on the way in and say wear the
mask during the rally will they space
people out so that they can maintain
some physical distance no the appear the
the answer appears to be they're not
going to do any of those things when a
rally needs a medical warning label
maybe the rally shouldn't be happening
now there's some very interesting
sociology and social psychology here
we've talked about trumpism as a cult
and we've interviewed cult experts and
this is sort of a test when Jim Jones
had his cult down in Guyana he did a
test run of having them drink cyanide
laced kool-aid where he didn't really
put the cyanide in the kool-aid this is
where the term to drink the kool-aid
originated and the reason Jim Jones did
this was to see how devoted his cult
followers were and then later on he
actually gave them the cyanide laced
kool-aid and nine hundred people died
this is the trumpism test are you
willing to go despite the waiver despite
it obviously not being safe to do an
event this big in this crowded to pledge
your support for the dear leader now you
might be wondering what a right-wing are
saying about this disclaimer I looked
around a lot of them are saying you
liberal goons every big event is going
to have a disclaimer like this until we
have a corona virus vaccine there's
nothing special about a Trump rally
having this waiver what's special is
that nobody else is having events with
10,000 people right now other events
might have a similar disclaimer if they
start having events this big if it's
safe to start but there are no such
events going on that's the whole point
the fact that such a disclaimer is
necessary when you're the only people
having an event this big that's a sign
you shouldn't be having the event at all
let me know what you think remember the
David Pakman show chess tournament is
Tuesday June 16th at 8 p.m. I hope
you'll play sign up for free at david
pakman.com
laughs chess the david pakman show at
david pakman.com the David Pakman show
depends on the support of our viewers
and listeners and one way to keep us
going is through patreon where you can
pledge as little as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash David Pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
one of the things that news stations are
supposed to do is that you're not
supposed to use bogus pictures or video
for reports and Fox News has been caught
doing exactly that this has to do with
the Seattle Capitol Hill autonomous zone
abbreviated or the acronym is Chas CH AZ
which has sort of formed in the
aftermath of the nationwide protests of
late and this is one of the clearest and
most undeniable violations of just basic
journalistic ethical standards that you
can imagine on Friday they were of
course running stories constantly on
their website about the Chazz this is an
area near Seattle's Capitol Hill where
protesters took over a few blocks after
police left the area and for much of the
day Fox News's web site was running
pictures of a guy with a long gun some
kind of protective vest a beanie and a
green mask standing in front of an Old
Navy with the window smashed out now
this was a completely fabricated what we
would call a collage image this scene
that was pictured on the Fox News
website didn't happen it was a
combination of a Getty image photo of a
guy with a gun who was at the pro set
protest zone on June 10th meaning last
Wednesday with an image from last month
of a smashed window and the entire
collage was completely and totally fake
now this wasn't just one fake image they
used another one had the same gunman
with the green mask with the long gun
appearing to stand at the start of the
CH as sort of placing him almost like he
was an armed sentry to that area now
think what you want about the Chazz
the guy in the green mask was not
actually doing what the pictures suggest
that he was doing it was totally and
completely fake these were doctored
images when the Seattle Times told Fox
News Fox News quietly pulled the
pictures when they were pressed by email
they said we have replaced our photo
illustration with the clearly delineated
images of a gunman and a shattered
storefront both of which were taken this
week in Seattle's autonomous zone except
that explanation is all
so untrue because the gunmen photo was
taken on June 10th the storefront image
with the broken window was from May 30th
so it was not taken from this week this
week being last week but this still
isn't the full story for a while on Fox
News's web site there was an image of a
building burning right above a bunch of
stories about protests in Seattle
remember that Friday was June 12th the
stories about Seattle that with all of
the stories below the image are about
Seattle and yet the picture that they're
showing was from st. Paul Minnesota two
weeks prior in May totally fake
fabricated narratives per the Seattle
Times on Saturday Fox apologized in an
editor's note posted saying that the
home page photos did not clearly
delineate the splicing together of
multiple images from different locations
and that they regret that these errors
took place so you can disagree about the
capitol hill autonomous zone the Chazz
it is mostly peaceful it's mostly
artists painting murals and the like but
there have been bad actors no question
people showing up with guns causing more
unrest but this Fox want to generate
more unrest by showing doctored photos
the answer is yes they do that's exactly
what they want to do or they simply
don't care about the truth of the
situation which is also possible and
also not good but understand that they
ran this stuff on their website for
hours and hours they got caught and the
next day
oops sorry and that's it and everybody
forgets about it and moves on zoom out
and look at the last three months we've
had distorted lies about testing fed to
us for weeks by the president and
repeated by Fox News until they just
stop talking about testing altogether
because that wasn't convenient
we had these distorted unemployment
numbers Oh with unemployment down to
thirteen point three footnote it's
really sixteen point three used by Trump
and Fox News in a sort of self
congratulatory tour fake descriptions of
protests as heavily riddled with an Tifa
not true as heavily violent
true and here they're adding to that
with fake doctored pictures from
protests from a range that is actually
multiple weeks in multiple places
presented as here's one discrete thing
that took place in Seattle it's
propaganda this is how propaganda works
and the Trump administration and Fox
News and OAM and other right wing
websites that I don't even want a name
are working together to spread this
stuff and we've got to make sure we
don't allow it to we have a voicemail
number which is two one nine two david p
here's a really good it really comes
down to an issue of math take a listen
to this question
hi David I was wondering if Trump loses
the popular vote let's say by a
landslide or by it like a large amount
is still possible for him to win the
electoral vote and when the election and
if you could explain that thank you yeah
so listen that there's there's two
answers to this right if you imagine
that all 50 state elections are
completely independent of each other
right that there is no there they are
uncorrelated then yeah there are
actually models which show that you can
get only 27 percent of the popular vote
and become president and win the
electoral college so that's never
happened that's an extreme example I
believe that the biggest popular vote
loss where they still won the electoral
college was 2016 Trump lost by more than
two points to Hillary Clinton in the
popular vote and still won because of
three states where his total margin was
about seventy five thousand votes George
W Bush in 2000 lost the popular vote by
a tiny bit and won the electoral college
so the the mathematical answer is you
could win the electoral college with
only twenty seven percent of the popular
vote it's never happened I imagine that
if Trump loses the popular vote by more
than three three or more he will lose
the electoral college because remember
it was like two point two that he lost
to Hillary by and he he just barely
squeaked it out if the margin in the
popular vote is
three or three and a half the odds of
Trump losing the popular vote by that
much and still winning the electoral
college would be I don't want to put a
number to it a statistician could do it
but it's got to be won in a very very
big big number I would actually be
interested to see data what are the odds
of winning electoral e if you lose by
three what are the odds of willing when
a winning electoral e if you lose by
four and the reason why it's so unlikely
is that elections are not uncorrelated
right if Donald Trump loses Florida by a
big margin it is very unlikely that he's
also not losing other important states
by a sizable margin which would make it
extremely unlikely that you would have
you know like a seven-point loss in the
popular vote and still somehow win
electoral e doesn't mean it's impossible
it's just never happened and I don't
expect it to I believe that the sort of
limit would probably be spitballing here
three or three and a half that if Trump
loses popular by three and a half he's
gonna lose electoral e if there is data
on this I haven't looked for it I would
love to see it like maybe we would find
out that oh you know if you lose by two
you still have a 25% of winning the the
electoral college if you lose by three
it goes down to only two percent and if
you lose by four it's only like one and
a thousand or something like that
there's probably some curve which
mathematicians have figured out I would
love to see it send it to me if you're
aware of it on the bonus show today we
will talk about a situation in which
election night in November could really
be election week or even election month
some of you probably have an idea of how
that could be we're also going to talk
about more statue related drama this
this is here in Boston that it's
happening and lastly in the context of
discussions about police protocol we are
going to talk about no-knock warrants
we've talked about no-knock warrants
before but I want to devote a little
more time to it so get a membership to
get access to the bonus show at join
pakman.com quick easy and cheap remember
that if you prefer a long-form audio
podcast to youtube clips you can
get our free podcast on iTunes stitcher
Spotify Pandora Google Play podcast
wherever you like to listen to your
podcasts and number three tomorrow night
join the chess tournament 8:00 p.m.
Eastern Tuesday June 16th david
pakman.com slash chess to sign up
breathe open to everyone and I hope to
see you there
thanks so much for watching today's a
full episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blink Asst the app
that lets you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blink astir free and
save 25% off of a subscription when you
go to blink is comm slash David Pakman
I've also included the link right
underneath this video